you know what's so funny that's probably
the most like I've had in my stomach in
a long time in Iran
[Music]
you know that's the thing that I like
that's the part I will never win because
of my gift of gab it gets it hides the
level of practicality that I'm speaking
to this is real now it's completely real
now I think that given your basically
this is what you had to say and I hope
that I'm an actor Lee it's a selfless
execution absolutely because my ambition
is to buy brands that companies like
this ruin buy them on a nickel on a
dollar and resurrect them yeah so I just
can't buy them all so might as well do
good along the way I'm running a small
start-up and it's a totally different
point right it's a sips like our hair
appeared on all of it just like
tolerate things that you would hundred
percent we can't afford to yeah thanks
for saying love yeah
vlog it's gonna be a short episode
mainly cuz d-roc overslept and because
we took a connecting red-eye from LA to
Chicago to here in Cincinnati where I
just gave a keynote and to be very frank
maybe it's cuz my good friend Craig
let's show Craig may because of his
words and he's always very straight but
kind or maybe just you know you have
these talks there moment sometimes
something really great just happened on
stage and I would say that what it was
was it's a moment that would I would say
synthesizes confirms reinforcements puts
the bow on this thesis that I'm living
on an everyday basis and I just [ __ ]
know I'm right
I don't know I have to say I just know
I'm right and I know that every day that
passes more good is gonna be happy
happening for me the amount of money
that I'm leaving on the table last seven
years for the historical brand equity of
being correct is enormous this is a
subtlety that I don't talk to you about
don't talk about in general it's because
I'm not cashing in on all the
opportunities because I'm trying to
spend time on doing a talk like this
that took up my whole day because the
inefficiencies of a license and out in
New York but the impact is greater in
the word of mouth of this collective
audience over a four to five year macro
so many people so many of you are
scrutinizing how to maximize more views
more likes more engagement more Adsense
pre-roll in your thing more sales more
t-shirt sales more speaking fees
short-term financial please please pay
attention to what I'm doing which is
make the financial you need to survive
to live and maybe to get that one or two
things you need a year to get your nuts
off and be happy a trip here a trip
there but then take all those other
dollar opportunities or dollars and
reinvest them into where you're going i
reinvest them in content creation in
distribution of my thoughts and
pontificating my treats and giving away
my best value to you and anybody who's
willing to consume it with the hopes and
thoughts that the Karma and the
realities of those truths in a 10-year
window create the opportunities for me
to trade on in
future please please please pay
attention to what I'm doing I raise
super empathetic I only display empathy
it doesn't make it right though
like and there's something clearly
happening yeah it's macro data the
brands are using the curio 97 97 percent
this is not you Oh 97 percent fortune
500 CPG brands decline that's upside
it's the over investment in TVC and
programmatic digital banners that's
really what it is a lot going on online
dating in Beart Airbnb this is real
stuff like it's real that's not coming
it's here how how easy is it to get to
you on page 147 of Vogue how easy is it
to get you to a banner pop about how
easy is it it's not it's not where your
attention is not your actual attention
not potential attention just real I mean
you've seen companies like I mean they
want invented the catalog will see us
everywhere it's yours today
that's why my friend if they're looking
at the history so if you don't change
you will die I think I'm gonna try to do
this more often when I'm lucky enough 50
rocks with me just tried something new
where I posted a B C or D on Twitter
where I'm gonna get feedback I have four
videos I'm sitting on instead of me kind
of arbitrarily looking at what the
team's chopping up through our
conversations I'm gonna start using
Twitter a little bit in a kind of like
one two three or four a B C or D post
the the videos up see what the feedback
is and then go and distribute any other
channels sometimes
we you know I'm I'm trading on the
arbitrary nature of what I'm feeling
which you know often does well but
there's so many opportunities to do
creative things so it's a new creative
pillar for Twitter make sure you follow
me there here's a new reason why get to
see almost everything and then it allows
me to use it as a siphoning mechanism to
what I then put down some of the other
platforms so you know do you know try
what I'm doing you know do what I'm
doing not what I'm saying
here's me in real time innovating trying
something new for four videos in a row
bang-bang-bang still trying to even post
and then looking at the feedback let's
see what happens
in somebody was a really interesting
platform you should go look at my my
trainer Jordan Sian he's so
knowledgeable I was like bro you're
sitting on knowledge put it out
so that he started making content that
was just valuable like breaking down
things and teaching people then
miraculously he went from four thousand
to two hundred fifty thousand followers
in nine months
why cuz he listened to the other things
that I told him which is instagrams
about hashtags if nobody's following you
do not post anything on Instagram
without your first comment being 1520
hashtags because hashtag is the currency
inside Instagram he got disciplined put
out content that was valuable to people
and then also put 30 hashtags and then
slowly but surely people started
discovering him and he had something of
value to that this is value exchange the
reason I've won for the last 20 years
and for the rest of my life in business
I'm trying to give the best value and
that is leverage for me to get what I
want
5149 I'm gonna give you more than I
asked and that's why I get plenty Thank
You Craig I don't know if you've heard
about the I got it
take a look thank you you're welcome if
you've heard about the hottest superhero
in the game yeah the hottest superhero
in the game do you know who it is
what's that that is this incredible
super hero called Airport Gary you're
gonna watch we transport things right
now
yes I go from normal businessman to
entrepreneurial superhero Airport t-rex
is your favorite part of every vlog I
have music now this is another day in
the life o Europe we're on Delta you
guys are in Delta
yeah and I'm away okay well I'm wrapping
up here thank you
how are you thank you thank you so much
it's very real to make your products and
struggled with burns to make it I guess
I don't know we talk a little bit old
school today it's um it's it's
systematic in the way that we're
rewarding people and their behavior mmm
it's just very big
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
way better than Batman